gilbert faku is a farmer his homeland is  remote near the bottom of africa  his life his wealth is in his farm and  the herd of cattley tens but what he  found in his backyard has brought him on  an extraordinary adventure  during the centuries of european  navigation toward the indian ocean ships  frequently passed gilbert's homeland on  south africa's eastern cape  one such trip ran aground leaving  countless spoils and gilbert is one of  the few who knows their location  upon dwelling  his fines are varied usually bits of  porcelain and beads but its most prized  possession is what keeps him coming back  and i've been doing a  teleport  it's a jewel encrusted pendant so  valuable yet he refuses to sell it  well for money that is  hi  you